[Music]
my name is Chanchal Chatterjee I work
for the Google cloud I am a cloud of AI
program manager I'll be accompanied by
Adam Hammond who is from quantify on one
of the use cases that we are going to
demonstrate here so today I'm going to
talk about model explain ability for
financial services industry from the
perspective of regulations so we are we
have been doing model explain ability
for a long time as a community but there
has been a bit of a confusion regarding
who the audience is a lot of us who are
developers are very focused on doing
model explain ability from standpoint of
understanding tomorrow so today I'm
going to take the perspective away from
that we are going to talk a bit about
how the financial industry regulators
view model explain ability which is the
most critical application of model
explain ability in the financial
industry and also one of the most
critical user model explain ability
period so moving forward we are going to
learn how some salt financial how
financial problems business critical
problems are solved in the area of risk
lending risk and insurance loss to use
cases we are going to look at well will
be explaining the models from a
regulators perspective the all the
solutions are built on the Google cloud
platform on the cloud machine learning
engine with complex deep learning models
will also demonstrate how we improve the
accuracy but yet we explain the models
for regulators and finally one of the
key pieces is we are going to convert
some of these models to a rule-based
solution in order to augment existing
rules so if you already have a
rule-based solution that is completely
approved by the regulator
then you may not want to add a
completely new model to the rule you'd
see lot of your financial services
customers pass for additional rules in
order to augment the rules and make it
better so that regulation becomes
regulatory approval becomes much easier
so we'll start with a few use cases of
model explain ability in the financial
services industry we'll also talk about
why we want to do model explanations we
want to talk briefly about some methods
some model explanation I think I'm going
to squeeze the slides because I don't
think that is very very relevant for
sake of time then we are going to talk
about types of explanations that
regulators typically want and will give
two examples one from lending risk the
other from insurance loss and we'll also
talk about a method that Google created
in order to augment existing rules okay
awesome so financial services use cases
there are many use cases in financial
services which is of high category high
use for model high importance for model
explain ability purposes so the first
one is credit lending this is a use case
we will cover the main purpose is to
comply to regulation and it's very high
importance transaction fraud this is
where model explain ability is needed in
order to create transparency is there
are many reasons for it but I just
highlighted one or two key reasons anti
money laundering
also transparency claims processing this
is where we want to automate the
explanations and the decisions so that
it's all supported in one transaction
and we also want to create transaction
transparency investment management
automated trading are also very high
degree of use for model explain ability
and for
automated decisions so the two use cases
we will consider one is lending risk the
other is insurance loss prevention and
Adam will present insurance loss
prevention use case which you worked on
why do model explanation so when
developers look at model explanation we
are typically looking at model
explanation from the perspective of
understanding the model whereas when the
regulator's look at model explanation
they are trying to increase their trust
in the model these are completely
different goals and this is why I made
this table in order to make it clear
what the two goals are they developers
look at model explanation to improve
performance of the models whereas
regulators look at model explanation in
order to reduce bias and increase
transparency most of our software
engineers should look at model
explanation in order to create better
algorithms in order to create a better
model is this a six-layer ResNet or ten
layer ResNet do we do it this way that
way all these differences are going to
come up in model explanation but
regulation regulators want to do model
explanation to comply to regulations and
the output for software engineers and
developers for model explanation is to
produce a better model a better software
but regulators want to produce a better
report so clearly the two audiences are
very different and therefore when you
look at the regulator's perspective the
entire scope of model explain ability
changes and how you do the explain
ability and how you report are very
different so this is a funny picture
which shows why we want to do model
explanation because we want to create
transparency we want to create trust we
want to create a better understanding
and in the u.s. we have to guidances one
is the SR 11/7 and the OSI 2011-12 which
are
basically guidance for model risk
management but when everybody uses them
then it almost becomes mandatory gtp are
in Europe is very important and there's
two articles that are written one by a
CC and the other by a large number of
academic and Industry people have
written the article together as to how
to do the governance of machine learning
so types and methods of machine learning
considering the time I'm going to go
through fast on this so model
interpretation has two variants one is
the global here that is local those of
you who are practitioners in machine
learning know this difference global is
when we take the entire aggregate of
data and we want to give the explanation
for the model on the entire collection
of data local is for a given transaction
like if we are trying to detect fraud
for one transaction that was considered
fraudulent you want to know why you
identified that transaction as fraud or
no fraud and it can be a single or a
small group of transactions but local
explain ability is basically for a
limited number of data so in terms of
methods we saw that there are over
thirty methods that are used in the
industry which cover a wide scope of
model explained ability we have only I
have only identified the key ones that
are most commonly used in the industry
and that are most common and highly
prevalent so the non-google ones that
are very common are line ok locally
interpretable models it's mostly a local
model I have a brief description the
second is anchors which is by the same
authors and shaft values which is very
common in the industry in terms of the
Google methods there are two that I want
to highlight one is called integrated
gradients and that one is very common
and that has been used very widely
within
I'll describe that in a little bit of
detail and the second is called tika
quantitative testing and concept
activation vector which is also another
model explain ability tool that Google
has created so going over these lime
stands for locally interpretable model
agnostic explanations and this is
primarily a local interpretation modern
methods although there is an extension
to global cholesky lime the key
attributes here is that it generates
data in the vicinity of the transaction
or the particular data and then it fits
the linear model and explains the linear
model it treats the features as
uncorrelated and the main issue with
lime lime is excellent in explaining
local models they doing a local
interpretation of models but the problem
here is that it has to go through the
process of generating synthetic data and
fitting the results to that so it
creates what we call a surrogate model
which is problematic in some cases some
regulators will not accept that and
secondly it takes time to do that so if
you have a large number of transactions
happening a million transactions per
second it will be very difficult to
apply this type of a complex technique
on a transaction-by-transaction basis
the second one is an innovation over
line which is called anchors which is
also a model agnostic explanation tool
so they basically generates logic and
rules around transactions and these high
precision rules are called anchors and
present local sufficient conditions for
these predictions I have linked the
paper and the github is all open source
it's by the same authors that wrote the
line this third one that is publicly
available is called shaft values
Shapley by it basically does the model
by comparing features with and without
it you take the feature out it basically
measures the sensitivity of a feature in
producing a certain outcome what is
great about Shapley is that it produces
the positive and negative effects on
outcomes for different features and we
have some results on that and because
you have to take all combinations of
features if you have let's say a model
in which you have 2000 features then
taking different combinations of twos
and threes and four and five makes
millions of combinations and therefore
it is very difficult to go through all
those combinations so they make some
approximations called Sabah's methods
and other methods and what it does is
that it finally creates an approximate
solution nevertheless Shapley is an
awesome method of doing model
explanation and is widely used in the
industry and it is also very fast and
accurate in real time transactions so
coming to the google methods the first
one is called integrated gradient switch
axiomatic attribution so deep networks
now this one is also a sensitivity type
measure it is also a local
interpretation tool and not geared
towards a global interpretation although
you can take a whole bunch of local
interpretations averaged them together
and call it global so the basic idea is
you perturb the features and inspect the
change of the features on the network's
prediction this method has been used in
over 20 Google products internally so
let's take a visual example of how this
method works so here's a picture of a
fireboat in front of the bridge so the
model says there's a fireboard so if you
look at the far right picture at this
end you'll see this is the picture the
fireboat and these are the gradients so
the problem with that is that the
gradients doesn't tell you anything
because it covers the entire
the bridge and the boat and the ocean
and everything so what we do in this
method is we take a baseline picture
which is a near dark picture at the far
end and then we look at the gradients
that come out of that picture and we see
some remnants of the bridge then as we
change the picture intensity from almost
dark to the full intensity different
gradients emerge and as you progress
through this different intensity of the
picture and as you see these different
gradients as you integrate through these
gradients then voila
the explanation comes out and you get a
beautiful picture of the gradients that
are relevant to the firebot itself and
that's how the integrated gradient
method works and we also found that the
gradients are most relevant during the
transition phase rather than the full
feature dimension and this is an
internal paper published and available
so next one is called decaf this is a
innovation over the axiomatic methods
this creates boundaries of different
features in order to judge the
sensitivity of the features effects on
the outputs so these are some of the
methods we have for model explanation
that are very common so next let's look
at the types of explanations that
regulators will be looking for the first
one that is most common is the
importance of the different features how
are the different features important so
if you label the features one through
nine or ten then you see that certain
features have a higher importance the
second thing you also want to look at
the standard deviations of those
features that is it's not important just
useful to take the average importance
but also how does that important is vary
from sample to sample like if you have
an importance which is point let's say
31 but the standard deviation is Twain
tea which means that the importance of
that feature varied widely over the
samples so you want to also look at the
standard deviations the second is the
positive and negative contributions or
features that is if certain inputs had a
positive effect on the outcome and
certain inputs had a negative effect on
the outcome so those are the two
important things that a regulator would
want the other two important things are
joint contributions of features or
inputs so let's say you had two inputs
one was let's say the loan amount and
the second one was the income of the
person how does the loan amount and
income relate to each other in terms of
the risk of credit lending so this is in
those two examples we'll take some
examples of how that happens and the
fourth one is and also we want to see
how does an input increase the outcome
and how does an input decrease the
outcome and then fourthly how does the
different samples affect the outcome the
different inputs vary from sample to
sample in increasing and decreasing the
outcome so let's go through the first
example and then I'll turn over to head
Adam for the second example loan risk
prediction this is a credit risk and
customer lifecycle value prediction
problem the data came from Freddie Mac
single-family home loan the ML best
solution is using user behavior patterns
and we are predicting to use a risk
which is the loan delinquency risk so
this is an example that is very relevant
to cases like student loan delinquencies
which has been announced as gone 29.1%
in some cases us is facing student loan
repayment crisis it can be repurposed to
market loans student loans auto loans
credit car loans personal loans the
partner on this
jet engine Pluto seven so so there is a
the we basically considered four classes
of outcomes and one is safe where the we
say that the creditor has been very safe
lender or has been very safe to land to
the the person second is moderate safe
and the percentages is shows that how
much of the data was in each of these
category as you can see very risky we
have very very little data so this is a
very unbalanced situation where we have
large amount of very safe lenders and a
lot of these financial services examples
we have very unbalanced data that is one
is one outcome has a very small amount
of data so we took three sets of data
and we built multiple models on that and
it is also very good we use deep
learning networks we use extra boost we
use random forests and we use nine place
based methods so by using all these
different algorithms we came up with a
very good result in which the case one
is safe and case two is moderate say if
the third one is model risky and the
fourth one is very risky obviously you
want to catch the last two very
accurately and we have 99% accuracy in
the last two the class two and three
which is model risky and risky and this
was a fantastic result regard so going
to model explanation on this problem we
had I took the top six inputs that were
that I'm going to use to explain the
models the first one is recency which is
the number of months ago the customer
had a recorded delinquency I stands for
number of months frequency how often the
customer had a recorded loan delinquency
value of which category
like 1 2 3 recency is the category
delinquency value with the 0 1 2 3 0 is
more safe and 3 is most risky credit
score we all know what that is
loan to value which loan to value means
what is the value of the asset and what
is the amount alone they took on the
answer let's say your home is worth
200,000 and you borrowed a hundred
thousand and your loan to value is 50
percent so the original unpaid balance
of the mortgage and the original
interest rate on the market again I can
take any one of these four values safe
modern safe more risky and risky so then
going through those four examples that I
gave for the regulator's look first one
is the feature important the second is
the positive and negative contributions
of inputs so we found out that resets
the score of two was one of the highest
important features which means that if
you were moderately risky before you
have a high propensity of becoming risky
and then recency score of safe means
also was a very high predictor of safety
and therefore recency score of zero and
one were also very high play unpaid
balance was also one of the high predict
a high important inputs in predicting
the outcome but that doesn't tell you
the whole story like I told you that
recency of 2 is probably a predictor of
risky recency of 0 is probably a
predictor of safe so we also want to
know which one of these inputs had a
positive contribution on the outcome and
a negative contribution which should
increase the outcome which decrease the
outcome right which predicted risky
which predictor safe so that's important
to know so we found that find early
increase the risk so the red line shows
that if that particular input increase
the risk and if any other input decrease
the risk so you want to know
which inputs had what degree of
contribution towards a positive outcome
or a negative outcome and also to what
degree like signed early had a huge
contribution in increasing the risk and
same as the discount whereas the
quantity how many loans the Turk had a
very small contribution in decreasing
risk the second thing is to look at the
correlations of features they on the
Left chart the vertical bars are 15 euro
15 year mortgage 20 year 25 and 30 year
and you can see 15 year Dawn's have
higher risks than 30-year loans is a
deduction you can make of this original
loan terms versus the original loan if
you look at the term alone and the
riskiness the green the blue means it
lowered risk whereas the red means it
increased the risk so 15-year had a high
degree of risk lowering and high degree
of risk increase so it had a wide
dispersion of a wide range of
contribution towards the risk on the
right side you can see California lon I
can I have results on many other cities
so whenever I go make presentation I can
switch to Illinois to New York to other
places but here we are talking in
California so you can say California
properties of a lower risk because even
though it makes a negative contribution
Andres which means that it increases the
risk but the increases of a smaller
amount compared the range of values the
intensity is smaller whereas any other
state the risk increase of a much higher
intensity and the decreases of a smaller
value so clearly there is a bigger risk
any other state but California and I
don't know if that is true or not but
this data shows that but so that's
that's a great example so what
come Adam he's going to talk about the
second use case insurance loss
prevention please thank you so the use
case said I wanted to speak about today
to all was insurance loss prevention so
here what we had done with a particular
property and casualty character was a
casualty carrier is they wanted to take
a look at the loss likelihood of their
particular policies so there are really
three elements that you can consider
when you're factoring losses so that's
the the frequency that happens so
whether it will occur not the severity
of it so how much will that loss be and
the timing of it for this particular
carrier in line of business in that
carrier the crucial thing for them was
whether or not a loss occurred because
the majority of those losses were
greater than the premium so they didn't
necessarily care about the severity
anytime you had a loss it would be an
issue to recreate in this analysis so
the data be a little bit different here
I took some open source data that's
available through Google data set search
and it was Iowa property and casualty
losses data set it also contains a
little bit information from the
surrounding states
so whereas John child chose a you know
active state that were in California I
chose one that don't visit too often for
conferences in Iowa but our solution was
email based and that's from policy
information and then one component that
we added to that was crime score details
so based on the location of a particular
policy the crime score could be
different and what we wanted to do is to
be able to predict that policies
likelihood of resulting in a loss some
examples in terms of why frequency is
important just linked a couple articles
in the top right and then different
examples of insurance that are out there
where some similar analysis can be done
is in property casualty which are really
focused on here but also we've seen it
in auto professional lines and health
insurance as well so first getting into
the data preparation and results so here
we didn't quite have the issues with
class imbalance to the same level as
John Charles use case but what we saw
was that the majority of policies result
not having a loss and then about 40%
resulted in having a loss from that data
set some additions that we made were a
loss flag so in the data set if you look
this up online it will just contain the
value of a particular loss so we wanted
to create a 1 0 since we're really just
looking for the likelihood and not the
severity we added some crime score index
information so again based on the
location which we randomized based on
the state that they're in we just added
crime score index data to that the
results that we were able to generate by
running just a pretty simple
straightforward random forest here was
an AZ of 0.9 1 and the way that we
compared it was with the false positive
rate and true positive rate basically at
smaller levels of that false positive
rate you want to have a higher true
positive rate meaning those that you
forecast or predict as positive are
actually going to be positive those that
we say will lose that will have a loss
actually do have a loss so when we look
at that at individual threshold levels
if we look at the false positive rate of
1% we can see that the true positive
rate there that we have is 40% and we
expect that to increase over time so at
10% of the false positives
we'd have 78% of the true positives so
anything really above an equal false
positive and true positive rate would
indicate a well performing model when we
go through this process there are a
couple of different ways that we make it
interpretable some of these we've seen
before so I'll gloss over them at a high
level but the first thing we do often
before we even start modeling is look at
the feature correlations so understand
whether or not there may be a positive
or negative x negative effect on the
outcome as well as if any features have
correlations with each other as your
independent features so what this will
do is shed light on the different
relationships that we see so you can
easily see a plot of the data if I go
down the diagonal axis from top right to
bottom right and then we could see the
scatter plots which would be between two
fields so if I look at the second row
first column basically that showcasing
the my scatter plot for premiums written
versus taxes paid so we
expect some alignment or correlation
there and then on the right hand side of
it so if I look at the first row second
column I'm seeing the correlation
between those two between premiums
written in taxes paid so this is often
how we begin to wrap our minds around
the data that we take a look at the
second thing that we do is once we
perform the model and we want to
understand a little bit more on that
global interpretability front as we look
at the feature importance so here what
we're just looking at is the mean
decrease in Gini and we're able to see
that the important features here are
crime index premiums written and line of
insurance now some child pointed out
earlier a great thing to add to this is
going to be your variance so you can
tell sample by sample how this changes
we didn't really have a high variance in
this one so didn't necessarily add them
to the visual but this also needs to be
combined with some sort of exploratory
analysis to understand the direction so
just because we know a feature is
important so if my crime index is
important to be able to see if I'll have
a loss or not you know from logic here I
think we can tell which direction it is
but you'd also want some exploratory
data analysis to say a higher crime
score would indicate a higher likelihood
of loss so this in isolation doesn't do
well but in combination with some
exploratory data analysis can act as a
way to interpret models the next one
that we wanted to look at was again more
on that local interpretability front and
the ones that we use most frequently
when we're looking at problems that are
in tabular structures are going to be
lime and going to be chef as judge y'all
already mentioned what those two things
are but here rather than looking at it
at an overall level one thing that we've
found useful and displaying information
to customers is looking at it at the
observation level so typically we may
see this in customer churn prediction
problems where they're trying to
identify for a particular customer the
specific reasons why that customer might
churn so rather than looking at all data
points across all features we look at
one specific observation across the
features so it might be for this
individual person that the written
premium and crime index are in
creasing their likelihood of churn the
tax is paid for whatever reason might be
decreasing their likelihood of churn
versus their industry that the Property
and Casualty loan was assigned to
increasing it in the location decreasing
it but understanding that on an
individual level and that it might
change from observation to observation
when I'm looking at both Lyman shap is
extraordinarily helpful all right thanks
Jan Schall now I'll hand it back to you
to convert to deep learning Thank You
Adam
such an excellent result the two use
cases so once again in each of these use
cases we identified four things that are
very important to regulators one is
which features sorry which inputs are
important and what is the intensity and
the variance of that secondly how do the
inputs correlate to the outcomes
contribute to the outcomes in a positive
way in a negative way that is which one
increases the outcome which decreases
the outcome in in Adams case it was lost
prediction in the example I took with
Brutus Evan was in delinquency loan
delinquency prediction that's the
outcome so which inputs make it larger
which inputs make it smaller the third
thing how do different inputs correlate
with each other in contributing to the
outcome so for example you might find
that a certain amount of loan may not
matter if it is taken from a certain
banks so maybe the large banks control
the loan industry we didn't find that
result but say let's we could find a
result like that it does not matter what
the amount is as long as you take it
from these banks right so sometimes you
see significant results like that and
sometimes you see how relationships
between you and the banking makes
difference and we sometimes find those
that's important criteria so the
correlation between different inputs
like the person like the lender and the
person who is lending to the
relationship matters so those are the
correlations
demonstrate that
and lastly is how do these different
inputs change from sample to sample very
important things and finally I'm going
to show a very strong and innovative
research that came out of Google
research by two folks Nicolas frost and
Jeff Geoffrey Hinton Geoffrey Hinton is
obviously very very very well known one
day Turing Award just a few days ago
Nicolas is a student and we thought that
this is a very significant result in
order to do what is called a deep a
augmenting of an existing rule by
creating a soft decision tree let's say
you built a complex model is my audience
still working let's say you built a
complex model a deep learning model but
a lot of the time your regulators will
not allow you to use that model they
will say distill it down to a few rules
that you can add to an existing solution
that already there which has past
regulation we want to add more rules to
that that's what we do so a typical
method to solve this problem would be to
take that deep learning network here's
the input here's the output and take
that same input and output and create a
random forest or a decision tree what
happens is that the results drastically
drop and let's say you're this complex
deep learning model did 99 percent all
of a sudden the decision tree does 80
percent so they've got to be a solution
in between where you take that deep
learning model and convert it to rules
but you do not lose the performance to
that drastic a degree that you've come
up with something in between and this
result is that that it produces a result
somewhere in between it basically takes
the deep learning model and tries to
understand what the inner workings of
the models are
the gradients at each layer so that you
can take that and make it into a
decision tree this particular picture on
the right is from a game called Connect
four and so the main idea of the soft
decision tree is to augment existing
rules find features that have
significant influence on the input on
the outcome and create a human
interpretable rule so a binary decision
tree that has learned filters at each of
the nodes okay is basically a
multinomial distribution function and
then when you do a stochastic gradient
on that which is the back propagation
algorithm by which you learn a deep
learning network then you use a equation
like that when you sum a multinomial
distribution over all layers of the
network and then you're running a
stochastic gradient descent so what we
do is that we took the Mint's data
m-miss data sorry and then we learned
the filters can be understood by a
person and then errors can be easily
understood and then the branch numbers
indicate the potential for the
classification
this is classification of digits okay
then the leaf number indicates the final
classification so what they did in their
research they took this complex decision
to the convolution neural network and to
learned layer by layer what the decision
was and they converted that to a
decision tree by that they got a 96%
accuracy in solving it that way so this
chart sort of demonstrates on three
examples one is M nests the other is
connect four and the letters so the deep
network gave very high accuracy like 99
percent letters 95 connect four is 87 to
0.7 but when you fit a decision tree
then the performance draw
drastically you can see eighty-seven
went to 78% yeah so anywhere from 5 to
20% in some instances as you can see 95%
dropped to 78 but using this decision
tree approach to disturb the soft
decision tree approach we got a result
in between so we got created a
human-readable rule which you can use to
augment your existing rules satisfy the
regulations but yet you don't have as
bad a performance as fitting in a simple
decision tree so that's all I have thank
you very much
[Music]